bonjour ici avec ma maman moi je tenais
à cette marche aujourd'hui laissez vous
pas recevoir par la quantité train qui
si la prestation en fait c'est un match
sur deux boules sur la ville
pennsylvanie ont le talent de la 13ème
rue
ça va jusqu'à la troisième russie
environ un kilomètre et demi plus loin
il ya des gens travaillent c'est
difficile de marcher à ce prix là tu
sais le sens de parler aussi ce que je
suis ici dans cette foule ya déjà de
toutes sortes d'origine qui a dit
énormément de jeunes des élèves quittant
leur disais je suis tel l'italien
l'école en me demandant s'il y aura pas
un jour quelqu'un qui va entrer avec des
armes vous comporte un panneau où une
affiche qui dit est ce que c'est moi le
prochain il ya des parents aussi de ces
jeunes hommes sont espérés par le
mouvement ces jeunes qui nul 2-2 de la
tuerie a parlé il ya un quart de jour et
demain mais aussi des gens qui sont là
parce que dans un hammam à l'école parce
que leurs enfants vont aller à l'école g
de speed
on aimerait se prend à rêver depuis des
années qu'on en parle
je pense en avoir donné l'été s'est
permis de réunir tous ces mouvements qui
existait depuis des années qu'ils sont
parfois bien organisés à l'échelle du
pays qui ont beaucoup de ressources pour
qu'on s'est tous mis ensemble avec
l'énergie de la reine ça avait
énormément de gens dans des vidéos hd
depuis 508 peut-être mort de +1
d'opinions beaucoup de monde qui sont
ici il ya des dizaines de marche comme
ceux ci dessous aujourd'hui 1 200 tonnes
stockées sur beaucoup d'espoir ce que
les gens disent et avec le mouvement
avec les gentilhommes les politiciens
devraient enfin et discuter
on réclame en est à dix ans des armes
aux états unis on réclame simplement
secondi ce sont des solutions sensées
notamment qu' il y ait des dames semi
automatique en circulation que les
produits
changer
[Musique]